what's the bifurcating that you're
talking about between
brett's approach and uh
your conception of how evolutions worked
you know it's not entirely clear because
he hasn't fully fleshed out
the things he's he's proposing um is it
commonly held
one area not in my experience
no not i mean in my time in academia i
hadn't heard
sort of this types of critiques that
he's been proposing
um but it's also i'm not exactly sure
the type of critiques he is proposing
because
um and i do get a little frustrated from
sometimes he'll post things that are
sort of these
uh he'll say something that you know
evolution is
i don't want to misquote him but this is
sort of paraphrasing
um you know in a crisis we haven't
really made any big
discoveries lately um and he kind of
in a way if you there's a way to read
them where he seems to be like tipping
his hat
towards like the intelligent design
people or something even though that's
not what he's really doing
but whenever i've sort of pressed him to
go into more detail he doesn't really go
into
crazy detail about uh what exactly he's
proposing he's he's proposed certain
things like
um these different behavioral uh types
that he called like explorer modes that
explains maybe how
how individuals can find new habitat uh
even though them exploring new habitat
wouldn't be
selected at like an individual level um
he might have a similar thing that
applies to just morphological traits and
sort of a
bounded mutations and things like that
and these are all ideas that
i'm totally open to it's just i haven't
heard them fleshed out in a way
that makes me think like there's there's
something there that's
that's really missing that i need to i
need to find out what this is
i like to have a podcast with him at
some point and just have him lay it all
out and him and heather are writing a
book and maybe he'll go they'll go in
more on this
and he's also suggested because he got
pushed back from people like michael
shermer too that was
saying like you know what are you saying
and also jerry coyne who's one of the
most
i guess prominent evolutionary
biologists sort of called him out in a
big
blog post that was just like what the
hell is going on like what are you what
are you talking about
and the response wasn't it wasn't
substantial it was just saying like
maybe i'll write a book on this and then
we can
move from there and so i was like that's
fine uh he doesn't tend to want to go
the
the publishing and academic journals
route because he
thinks there's sort of a gated
institutional narrative and they're
they're gonna
suppress them even though you can still
submit these things online to
open uh what it's like the um
there's these open journals that is you
can you can it's like a pre-print
service where you can
upload things online so they can't
suppress your ideas
before they're published like you get
your ideas published on
uh on one of these open source areas
before they get accepted
um and it's i just really i really
wish both brett and his brother would
sort of go that route and actual
actually write up the paper whether or
not you're going to submit it to a
journal
but just have something that we can look
at where i can actually assess what's
being talked about here because
it's just it's just a big black box and
maybe they're
geniuses who are going to just turn the
paradigm of evolution or
or maybe not like i just have nothing to
go off of so i guess we'll see
it definitely feels like a fan of bread
dude this isn't like there's not a con
i'm not like
trying to butt heads with him i'm just i
want to see more because he's he's a
smart guy he's the kind of person that i
could see maybe coming up with some
brilliant idea
uh i just as a biologist myself i
i just want to know more i'm super
interested in what he what he's
proposing
it definitely feels to me like him and
eric have had
such burnt finger syndrome
from the traditional avenues of academia
that um it kind of doesn't surprise me i
didn't know that about their
aversion to publishing in traditional
journals and putting together the papers
in the normal way but it totally doesn't
surprise me given what i know about
their
background yeah i mean it's not even
that they won't publish in journals like
i'm fine if they just publish it on a
blog or something you know to just just
write the paper so i can see where it is
and we can assess it on its
on its own merits right if you if you
are listening my friend there is a lot
of people out here that want to know
what's going on
[Music]